[Music]
I was browsing the website
comingsoon.net when I came across an
interesting video it was a meditation
video with Kung Fu Panda now that really
piqued my interest because I spent 10
years in the martial arts I gained my
second degree black belt in kung fu
commercial break if you've never done it
now is a great time to check out our
video called the dragon revealed it's
with one of my friends Eric Wilson and
we'll put the link for that video in the
description below so at first when I
looked at this Kung Fu Panda video I
thought it was 4 minutes and then I
realized it wasn't 4 minutes it was 4
hours and I'm just imagining all the
kids who are sitting down in front of
this thing for long periods of time now
learning the basics of Eastern religion
and in particular meditation you'll
notice how Kung Fu Panda is seated it
appears like he's sitting in the sasana
position which is a variation of the
lotus position notice how his breath is
very
focused hey there I'm the Dragon Warrior
today I'll be guiding you with an inner
peace meditation to help you let go of
the stress of the
[Music]
day breathe in through the
nose out through the mouth this is
important because it's the breathing or
the chi that allows the body to prepare
the mind for meditation notice the
importance of Zen meditation according
to karate Grandmaster maso Yama always
more vital to karate than techniques or
strength is the spiritual element that
lets you move and act with complete
freedom in striving to enter the proper
frame of mind Zen meditation is of great
importance the man who wants to walk the
way of karate cannot afford to neglect
Zen and spiritual training so in his
mind the meditation is more important
than the physical
training now the Lotus position is
something that came into the martial
arts via Hinduism notice what Hinduism
today says in the postures of Hatha Yoga
the Lotus position pod masana is adopted
by those striving to reach the highest
level of Consciousness which itself is
found in the Thousand petal Lotus chakra
at the top of the head Hinduism also
teaches that the otman which is your
essential self dwells in the Lotus
within the heart and that this is the
place where the self God dwells author
and teacher of martial arts Dr Yang said
this meditation has been widely
practiced in the East often these
meditators lived in obscurity in the
mountains through meditation they
comprehended the doubt of mankind and of
nature I believe the documents written
by these Pioneers are amongst the most
precious Treasures mankind possesses now
there is an interesting concept that
he's bringing out here the da the da in
Chinese philosophy is the way but the
way of what well the way of Harmony and
understanding dosm doesn't make a rigid
division between body and spirit these
things all work together for holistic
growth if you've ever taken martial arts
especially the Japanese variety you
would have gone to a dojo what is a JoJo
the translation of the term is the place
of the way so this is the place where
you are to get your physical and
spiritual instruction now this is all
evident even in the language if you look
at the characters that make up these
words you can see how they are Rel
related in Chinese Japanese Korean
they're all the same kanji you like an
ad Dojo or a DA Jang or da Jang to a
temple a building devoted to Worship in
English we refer to the place where the
shallon monks train as temples as ly
cizer put it the dojo is a destination
it's a place to go it's sacred ground no
one ends up in a dojo by mistake for
many of us it's like coming home
meditation whether in the martial arts
or yoga is not the same as biblical
meditation these forms of meditation
teach that you should empty your mind
God's form of meditation is to fill the
Mind notice what it says in Philippians
4:8 finally Brethren whatsoever things
are true honest just pure lovely good
report if there be any virtue and if
there be any praise think on these
things God's admonition for meditation
is to think he doesn't want us to have
an empty mind he wants us to have his
mind
for who has known the mind of the Lord
that he may instruct him but we have the
mind of Christ you might think that as a
Christian you can separate the spiritual
aspects of Eastern religion like
meditation from your Christian
experience however according to the yoga
and martial arts Masters you cannot Guin
Funakoshi founder of shodokan karate and
widely recognized as the father of
modern karate said this Spiritual
Development is Paramount technical
skills are merely in means to an end you
may train for a long time but if you
merely move your hands and feet and jump
up and down like a puppet learning
karate is not very different from
learning a dance you will never have
reached the heart of the matter you will
have failed to grasp the quintessence of
karate do yoga was secularized to get
rid of any taint of pagan tradition this
practice The Savvy marketers claimed was
a spiritual path but not a religious one
to calm the committed Christians who
wanted to hang on to Jesus while doing
the Sana mascara or obeses to the
Sun from the Eastern Viewpoint and
especially the yoga Traditions it is
impossible to separate yoga from the
deities they represent the universal
forces of creation and transformation
what should you meditate on the Bible
gives the answer in Psalm
77:12 I will also meditate on all your
work and talk of all your
Deeds
[Music]